across the river from where the queen's
coffin will lie in state is where
vanessa and ann will spend the next 48
hours in an effort to secure their place
at the front of the queue
it might be miles they said might be
seven miles we don't know and they might
also stop at some point if it's
overcrowding so you wanted to pay the
fire you just wanted to make sure i get
the position and get the chance to pay
my last respect
the advice has been to avoid lining up
yet
but anne's dedication spans decades you
know you're always used to seeing the
queen out and about getting out of this
magnificent car wonderful hats and
dresses on and
beautifully made up and pearls and
jewels
and and to think of her majesty
you know well resting in peace really
will be very difficult
anne was also one of the 200 000 that
came to see the queen mother lion state
in 2002
long queues snaked down the river thames
20 years on london will witness those
scenes once again the queue will start
two miles from here near tower bridge
they will snake all the way down the
south of the river until they reach here
lambeth bridge they'll cross it and then
turn right and head towards the palace
of westminster
only small bags will be permitted all
food and drink will need to be consumed
before people reach the front of the
queue at westminster hall and only clear
flasks and bottles will be allowed this
is a huge moment for the country a huge
challenge for those managing security
all at a time when world leaders will
also descend on the capital an
unenviable task for the mets new
commander just weeks into the job
orchestrating a plan that's been built
for years
they've been working with colleagues
from
across government and they're all
households and others as you would
expect so we will have a
safe event but we're going to be putting
thousands of offices into this
because of
the level of security required and the
millions of people who want to pay their
respects
those paying their respects continue to
flood the parks around the palace the
cue to see the queen's coffin will keep
moving at pace too
hoomer came to see the queen mother at
midnight but many like her are undecided
whether they'll make the journey this
time
you can see that
with everybody i mean
this is a
just the the amount of people in the
turnout
and the um
the flowers
and
the time the effort that everybody is
making
because she means a lot to everybody
britain's last reigning monarch drew in
crowds of hundreds of thousands in 1952
as king george vi lay in state
this week his daughter the queen will do
the same with a likely turnout that will
show the great lengths the nation will
go for their final farewell ashland
horrorlax sky news in central london